dan carlin actually has this um
um episode
of hardcore history uh on
painfultainment oh that episode is
[ __ ] it's dark because it he kind of
goes through human history and says like
we as humans seem to enjoy
secretly enjoy or used to be openly
enjoyed sort of the torture
and the death watching the death and
torture of other humans i do think
if people were consenting
we should be allowed to have gladiator
gladiatorial
matches
but consent is hard to achieve in those
situations it always starts getting
slippery like it could be also forced
cons like it starts getting weird yeah
yeah there's way too much excitement
that this is what he highlights there's
something about human nature that wants
to see that violence and it's really
dark
and you hope that we can sort of
overcome that aspect of human nature but
that's still one
within us somewhere well i think that's
what we're doing right now i i have this
theory that um what is very important
about the current moment is that
um all of evolution has been survival of
the fittest up until now and um at some
point you know it's kind of the lines
are kind of fuzzy but
in the recent
past or maybe even just right now we're
getting to this point
where
we
can choose intelligent design
like we
probably since like the integration of
the iphone like we are becoming cyborgs
like
our brains are fundamentally changed
everyone who grew up with electronics we
are fundamentally different from
previous from homo sapiens i call us
homo techno i i think we have evolved
into homo techno which is like
essentially a new species like um if you
if you look at the way if you mr if you
took an mri of my brain and you took an
mri of like a
medieval brain i think it would be very
different the way the way that it has
evolved do you think when historians
look back at this time they'll see like
this was a fundamental shift to what a
human being is i think i i i do not
think we're we are still homo sapiens i
believe we are homo techno and i i think
we have evolved
um and
uh
and i think right now the way we are
evolving um we can we can choose how we
do that and i think we're being very
reckless about how we're doing that like
we're just having social media but i
think this idea that like this is a time
to choose intelligent design should be
taken very seriously it like now is the
moment to reprogram the human computer
um you know it's like if you go blind um
your uh visual cortex will get taken
over with um other functions we can
choose our own evolution we can change
the way our brains work and so we
actually have a huge responsibility to
do that and i think
i'm not sure who should be responsible
for that but there's definitely not
adequate education we're being inundated
with all this technology that is
fundamentally changing um the physical
structure of our brains and we are not
um adequately responding to to that
to choose how we want to evolve and we
could evolve
we could be really whatever we want and
i think this is a really important time
and i think if we choose correctly and
we choose wisely
consciousness could exist for
a very long time and integration with ai
could be extremely positive
and i don't think enough people are
focusing on this specific situation do
you think we might irreversibly screw
things up if we get things wrong now
because like the flip side of that seems
humans are pretty adaptive so maybe the
way we figure things out is by screwing
it up like social media over a
generation we'll see the negative
effects of social media and then we
build new social medias and we just keep
improving stuff and then we learn the
failure from the failures of the past
because humans seem to be really
adaptive on the flip side
you we can get it wrong in a way where
like literally we create weapons of war
or increase hate
past a certain threshold we really do a
lot of damage i mean i think we're
optimized to notice the negative things
but i would actually say
um
you know one of the things that i think
people aren't noticing is like if you
look at silicon valley and you look at
like whatever the tech technocracy like
what's been happening there like it's
like when silicon valley started it was
all just like facebook and
all this like for-profit crap that like
really
wasn't particular i guess it was useful
but it was it's sort of
just like whatever
um but like now you see like lab-grown
meat like compostable
um or like biodegradable
cut like a single use cutlery or like um
you know like meditation apps you know i
i think uh we are actually
evolving and changing and technology is
changing i i think they're just
maybe
there isn't quite enough education
about this and also i don't know if
there's like quite enough incentive for
it because i i think the way capitalism
works um
what we define as profit
we're we're also working on an old model
of what we define as profit i i really
think
if we changed
um
the idea of profit to include social
good you can have like economic profit
social good also counting as profit
would incentivize things that are more
useful and more whatever spiritual
technology or like positive technology
or um you know
things that help reprogram the human
computer in a good way or things that um
help us
intelligently design
our new brains yeah there's no reason
why within the framework of capitalism
the word profit or the idea of profit
can't also incorporate you know the
well-being of a human being so like
long-term well-being long-term happiness
you